when we think about diversity in Las
Vegas one of the many spots that come to
mind is Spring Mountain filled with
Asian culture and Cuisine but during the
pandemic many businesses suffered and
were forced to close because we live in
the community we share like every few
days oh my God such and such restaurant
closed
prior to the pandemic they were doing
quite well Dr Christopher Choi and his
wife Sydney are business owners and both
now part of Asian American Pacific
Islander Chamber of Commerce a first of
its kind catering to all members of the
Asian community in Nevada we provide the
translation service which is very
important of as a minority they had a
soft launch during the pandemic a time
where struggling businesses needed help
the most during this time the group
helped with applications for PPE loans
and as there was a rise in Asian hate
crime they stepped in the API as a group
who is underrepresented uh politically
right
perhaps try to change that and try to
advocate for our own rights offering
training in diversity equity and
inclusion they'll be having their first
networking event in person on Tuesday
hoping to meet future Asian Community
leaders Victoria Saha 8 News Now